one day away from the opening of the
window that would allow teams to trade
players
at a reduced cap charge if the player
has multiple years and multiple years of
dead money left that would accelerate
into this year as of tomorrow no
acceleration you just take the cap
charge we're going to take
anyway this year for whatever signing
bonus money or other prorated money
already was paid so it's an inducement
to engage in trades as of june 2 and for
five weeks now we've been monitoring the
possibility that julio jones will be
traded
there still isn't an overwhelming
obvious
this is the team that's going to trade
for him which makes me still think the
patriots are going to come out of
nowhere and trade for him but you know
we reported over the weekend chris that
in league circles the prevailing thought
is the titans for a second round pick
that's where julio jones is going to go
that doesn't mean it's going to happen
that's just what people believe but
again you never know when bill
belichick's gonna swoop in out of
nowhere and get a deal done that we
didn't think he was gonna do yeah i mean
this is the common thought it makes a
lot of sense like we've talked about
from from both sides both angles i
understand julio jones wanting to go
there they have a real need for him like
you know your point mike there about the
patriots too
you're right i i don't hold them out of
this first off i mean hey john
robinson's the gm for the titans he came
from new england you know there's
certain things and formulas and scouting
that i think you know teams like that
there's there's a common ground on what
they like in players and all those
things i will say this though you're
right new england
hovering on the outside as long as the
price doesn't get too expensive
they're gonna be in this and i would
think second round would be still the
conversation where they could swoop in
and steal a julio jones or do something
like that but i mean as it stands right
now it seems to be the team
i hear the most about from friends in
the nfl that seem to think this is going
on but you're right i don't know
anything of like oh a deal is imminent
or it's right around the corner or you
know they're they're really deep into
talks i haven't heard anything like that
quite yet it doesn't sound like you have
either huh and and other teams emerged
and and some receded over the weekend
the rams were in play i'm told they're
definitely out they don't have a first
round pick yeah 2024 right not that not
that they were going to put a
first-round pick on the table although
on that point too the the report that a
first-round pick is part of a package
for julio jones most people around the
league don't believe that there would be
a straight first-round pick for julio
jones someone explained it to me over
the weekend that it's entirely possible
that there's been an offer made of a
first round pick to the falcons and
julio jones and a second round pick
going the other direction which would
make a hell of a lot more sense right
that team gives up a one gets julio
jones and receives a two it's better for
the falcons to just get a second round
pick for julio jones yeah well we got a
first round pick so what you gave up a
second round pick to get it and it may
be a high first round pick next year if
the falcons don't get out of this funk
quickly so
so so i think there was to the extent
that there is a first round pick that's
been mentioned discussed offered it's
come with enough
conditions
including give us a second round pick
back that it's not being regarded as a
serious offer yeah yeah well i i i could
i could see that like you know and i
think again that's going to be like you
know the million-dollar question as we
dive into this julio jones stuff is just
you know are there going to be more
teams involved and then it's just going
to be about
you know kind of the dance of figuring
out what makes sense on the chart as far
as value and things like that and then
you know everything you've mentioned
over the last few weeks the contract
situation what they want to do with the
money or like you're talking about
compensation back to the to the falcons
oh hey we gave you a first round you
know that seems to be the thing that the
teams are going to have to juggle around
the most i mean definitely and you know
when i do look at it to me again i just
bring it back to the tennessee titans to
where it makes the most sense for them
to be that team it does i mean they're a
team that i think we both agrees in the
window they made some big time
adjustments in the off season as far as
you know free agency
sign a bud dupree to add to the pass
rush you know they they bolstered their
secondary offense they they need another
guy it can't just be aj aj brown and
derek henry and i do look at them and i
think you do too mike right as a team
that's in the super bowl window to where
this opens the window up even more if
you get a guy like julio jones to come
into town
and and if you get a julio jones who is
healthy yeah motivated determined and
there's a thought out there
that
that he will be
motivated and determined now healthy you
can never guarantee but one of the
caveats that whoever trades for julio
jones needs to keep in mind we posted
this i think yesterday
the thinking is he's going to want a new
contract either through the door or
comes out has a huge
2021 he's going to want it after that
you know this idea that hey you're
getting julio jones for three years 38
million it's about 12 million in change
per year no no no no no that's not what
you're getting you're getting julio
jones maybe for 15.3 this year after
this year if he does
decide to go forward under the terms of
his current deal and not say i want a
new contract if he comes out and has a
big year you're gonna have to pay him
after this year that's part of what you
have to factor into this whatever you
give up to get him you're getting a guy
and you're inheriting whatever
discontent he may have contractually and
people can say well he's making 22
million a year
well yeah but he's got three years left
at 38. once a player's already cashed
the checks from the front loaded portion
of the contract they're not thinking i'm
getting 22 million a year they're
looking at what they have now going
forward and they're saying i'm only
getting 12 million a year something's
wrong with this picture
uh you gotta you gotta factor this in
it's gotta be part of the conversation
you're right i don't know if it's
something that
it doesn't seem to be
like when we had the deandre hopkins
trade a few years ago right mike with
the houston texans arizona cardinals one
of the first things we heard out of the
out of the gate was hey one of the
reasons we think the texans are doing
this through league circles was
deandre hopkins wanted more money right
and that was an issue
i i i haven't heard that yet i mean i'm
i'm with you but i don't i don't hear
that being like the jump off point for
the trade or anything like that so but
you're right i think that you hops out
and you're right not that he wants more
money he wants out but once he gets in a
new landing spot you gotta be worried
about it i know that's where i look at
like and when i think of that aspect of
it that's where i go into like new
england and i think about them when it
comes to that stuff and i just go well i
can't imagine bill being happy with that
scenario oh like let me just let's let's
get a player here and
see how the year goes and if he does
real good then oh man he's going to hold
our feet over the fire and want more
money and deal with that and all that
crap and oh wait we just gave a first
round pick or a second round pick to get
you and do all those issues you know
that is definitely something you're
gonna have to balance and have a feel
for talking to his agent and getting a
feel from julio jones before this trade
as far as where his mind might be in
that conversation
and that's the thing when you don't have
a lot of high-end receivers on your team
for the past 20 years you don't have
many situations like this where high-end
receivers want to be paid remember how
they dealt with randy moss when he
became a free agent after the 2007
season
he became a free agent
after that season they didn't apply the
franchise tag they didn't want to
restrain him they played it the right
way and he ultimately took three years
27 million which seemed like a lot at
the time it shows you how much the cap's
changed since then but you you have to
deal with these guys a certain way and
bill belichick could look at this
situation and say there's no way out of
this maze that doesn't entail blowing
our salary structure for a guy who may
be happy for one year
but come 2022 we're gonna have a problem
financially so that's something that
definitely needs to be kept in mind and
maybe one of the reasons why there
aren't three or four teams that are
jostling
and clamoring yeah to try to make this
happen i think it's a few things right i
mean there's that possibility
there's the trade aspect like we talked
about you know as far as figuring out
all the things that need to be done
there whether it's you know the
atlanta paying part of the contract this
year whatever the value all of that his
health status where is he there like
you've talked about i mean listen i'm
with you mike i would bet that he's
gonna be motivated new team new place
you know be on his a game
but you know you still if you're making
a trade for a guy and giving away a
first or second round pick you don't
want a guy that you're looking at going
okay maybe he's got one more good year
left in him and then he's gonna fall
apart and i think that's what's gonna
scare people too in this whole
conversation i mean you just look at the
last three years of stats and you know
oh injuries last year
you see everything fell off to a degree
and we know that's part of his history
and that's going to be scary that's
where i just i don't know where this
goes and i don't know
i just
where last week i was kind of getting
the feeling we were going to get more
teams involved in this and this could
like raise the price
now it's like we sit here and i go i
don't know really if anybody's going to
really ever get involved here other than
maybe one or two teams that we're
talking about and is anybody else going
to really dive in here and and do
anything substantial
as to the hamstring situation yeah this
is another complicating factor and it's
a good news bad news thing for whoever
would trade for julio jones there is
this thought and he wouldn't be the
first and he won't be the last that he
could have played
more than he played last year but it was
a manifestation of his discontent with
the organization so that hamstring
injury that if you were perfectly happy
and everything was great you'd find a
way to play through it right all of a
sudden that hamstring injury becomes
something that you choose not to play
through because you're not happy with
your situation it's an easy way
to to show internally things aren't good
so and again that he's not the first
wouldn't be the last and the good news
is maybe he's a lot healthier maybe this
is like randy moss in 2007 everyone
thought he was washed up the bad news is
that's part of what you're getting right
if you trade for julio jones you better
make him happy because if he's not and
he's got a little bit of a hamstring
tweak he's not going to play yeah and
you're not going to have him on the
field yeah you just have to understand
that going in seahawks entered the chat
over the weekend there was an espn
report that they have talked to the
atlanta falcons about this chris when we
did the draft last thursday of ideal
destinations i picked the seahawks one
of the reasons is hey if you want to
play kate russell wilson go get julio
jones which makes me think they probably
won't go get julio jones because they
don't seem to be inclined to play kate
russell wilson no they don't they never
seems to be like the driving force
that's for sure i mean i'm i'm not
surprised to hear the seahawks involved
in this because i feel like the seahawks
always get involved they're one of those
teams that always seems to kind of dip
their toe in the water as far as these
type of conversations go just to see
where it's at because they are again
another one of those teams we talk about
a lot that you know they're always
looking to push their chips in the
middle of the table go we're all in
we're going we're trying to win the
super bowl this year and i respect that
about them but
i i mean as much as like
i guess i need to see their offense and
how it works because what i would tell
you right now from what i've seen the
last few years i don't even know how
julio jones would work up there you know
i i have i mean there's times mike i
feel like we talked about this a lot
during the year where i'd go like they
can't even get the ball to dk metcalf in
certain games they can't even find ways
to do that now i know they got a new
offensive program up there and they're
going to be different but uh i it just
doesn't seem like the offense that's
been capable of spreading the wealth
that way that's where i'm not sure if it
makes sense to me that way either
yeah look i i agree it's gonna be hard
to do you better have a plan and as you
said last week shane waldron the new
offensive coordinator a lot of three
receiver stuff there is but yes you've
got it you've got to make it work and i
don't see pete carroll signing off on
this idea we're going to have a high
flying
aerial offense he wants to run the ball
and now all of a sudden we have to keep
d.k metcalf tyler lockett and julio
jones happy and we've got russell wilson
at 35 million a year and julio jones is
going to want a new contract after this
year yeah i don't see it sooner and dk
metcalf has the window open on a new
contract that's him after this boom you
just you just laid it out that's why
it's not happening you just laid it all
out the russell wilson deal julio might
want more money
dk's coming very soon they're already
paying tyler locket i think we just
talked that out right there that's why
that that i would be shocked if it
happens just for the reasons you just
explained
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports